simge is packing up her life
picking up urgent medicine for her
diabetic father
grabbing what she can
from what little is left of her family
home in Adana
so I'm so confused actually because
there's my room but
this is where she was when the
earthquake hit
I was sitting in my room it started
shaking and then I realized the building
was falling on top of me then I fled to
the hallway and shut the door and when I
did the whole wall came down
she's been told by inspectors the
building will be reinforced and at some
point her family can return but that
seems a long way off
[Music]
and with every day the cracks show
Growing anger at poor building standards
and government amnesties that forgave
faults in millions of homes who do you
think's to blame if anyone here
there has been a void in the inspection
process local administrations like
municipalities and contractors void of
any ethics have cut corners and tried to
make money they've used loopholes in the
law for their personal gain do you think
the amnesties are part of the problem
like committing a murder
[Music]
there were warnings last year the
environment Minister said 6.8 million
homes in Turkey were considered risky
and that 1.5 million needed to be torn
down
urgently
what really strikes you here is you've
got these buildings standing side by
side that face completely different
Fates one obliterated the other
completely intact and there are lots of
buildings like this with huge cracks in
them now they'll have to be inspected
and if there is structural damage
they'll have to be torn down
is desperate to get back into her home
to recover the bodies of her daughter
and Grandson
they're gone they're gone she cries I
cannot breathe
it is a hellish landscape ruins
regression and Mustafa sees greed
in Turkey there is no progress we're
always going backwards Architects
contractors they're just looking at how
they can steal how they can gain
foreign
Still Moments this feels like a museum
of mourning
no one chose to visit of course and yet
so many will struggle to leave
Cordelia Lynch Sky News iskandarin
turkey